he said no
[Music]
Nicki Minaj goes all out for her son's
second birthday with an over-the-top
minions themed backyard Bash
[Applause]
[Music]
on Monday the rapper who shares her son
who may lovingly call Papa Bear with her
hubby Kenneth Petty posted tons of pics
and clips from the celebration including
custom t-shirts a multi-tier minion cake
minion desserts lots and lots of minion
balloons a minion balloon wall a bounce
house and ice cream machine cotton candy
machine smoothie machine popcorn station
slime Station Lego hat making station
coloring station and face painting this
is crazy oh and let's not forget the
dance floor where Papa Bear showed off
his adorable moves
[Music]
the toddler also proved he's a natural
on the mic just like his mommy
[Music]
Nikki posed with her fam for a few cute
selfies and shared these sweet snaps to
Instagram writing alongside it quote
your dad and I love you so much you make
us so happy you're perfect thank you for
giving Mom a new meaning to life God
cover you always my loving side Nikki
and Kenneth tied the knot back in 2019
and welcome Papa Bear their first child
nearly a year later when I was little I
always imagined you know princess and
marriage and wedding the wedding and now
it's more to me about
the the life the future the love the
partnership then the wedding which is so
strange because I didn't expect myself
to be one of those people who didn't
care about the hoopla but I really don't
and ever since he's made many sweet
appearances on Nikki's social media
Pages like back in August when Nikki's
tracks super freaky girl debuted in the
number one spot on Billboard's Hot 100
making it the first solo female rap
track to top the chart since 1998. ah
well that was that's always the goal I
always want to be great at anything I do
are you
okay
and she celebrated the Milestone moment
with her little boy
[Music]
so whether she's celebrating her work
wins with Papa Bear
that's cool or ringing in his birthday
[Music]
one thing's for sure Nikki is one super
sweet mama
foreign